this is Startalk this is Startalk Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist I work at the American
Museum of Natural History where I serve
as the director of the Hayden
Planetarium you all invited
tell me come to the front tell me you
know me and they'll still charge you 20
to the punker
but it's a pardon it support what is
that Park
all right that's Bill Nye bill thanks
for coming on to start on it's great to
be oh my gosh and I got to call it my
favorite thing ever ever and Chuck nice
yes I am here thanks for coming always
we are now in cosmic queries cosmic
queries I always wanted to come to
queries after hours yes while we're
doing it after hours and this is of
course where we take increase from all
across the interwebs the interweb
Internet's our fan base Hawks fan day
listeners you know from everywhere and
they ask you questions we do not share
the questions with you today of course
we have the inimitable Bill Nye with us
but here's that here's the place an
expert so the topic today is what the
topic today is rocky sciences high right
and so well I know a little song about
rocket science whatever I know Bill Nye
knows more okay so I figured I'm not
gonna take this alone right so I'm with
stupid on the air no bill you take that
way
I could do it but yeah I got you here
that's pressure bill you work for Boeing
you're engineer airplanes
what's your rocket like no but no but
you've you've thought about rockets in
your life I thought deeply well there
you have Marshall I thought lightly
about rockets okay so chuckle straighten
you know between the two of you we might
just get somewhere all right let's jump
right into this our daughters question
is from Paul pure CEO or her CHEO and
Paul is coming to us from Twitter Paul
says this how many benefits come from
some of the shuttle disasters we have
witnessed well there's only been two
disasters and we say some of them have
been toothed shell disaster
general something every time are you
kidding yes we learn things by the way
this is the next rockets are not going
to have the plane mounted on the side
that's not going to happen when people
greatly complicated I mean the Space
Shuttle Orbiter is it has the engine
under its belly and they're adjacent to
one another we're not gonna do that
again
we learned that put it right on top put
it right on or take off like an airplane
from a runway that would be the ultimate
it takes a very lightweight airframe
space frame structure not saying it's
not doable there's not there okay
however isn't it true that that wasn't a
good idea even without the accidents
absolutely
what do we learn from the accidents
there's a challenger in 1980
yes ladies no nobody 66 absolutely yes
86 and then Columbia yep and 2001 yes
February 2002 take the ice seriously
folks the hole in the insulation and you
got trouble well like the ice comes from
condensation that would only happen
because they're in a humid environment
called Florida I think you can I used
even in New Mexico you think so yeah hmm
20 percent humidity is gonna get you a
so yeah things are cold all right all
right now don't take it seriously this
isn't a problem when you have it mounted
on the side and the ice falls down on
your installation well now if your top
of it then the ice falls down it just
hisses belong back on huh Chuck you
bitching over there that's what we know
that's what we learned that gets yeah
I'd heard from my rocket people that
rocket disasters are our opportunities
rich and learning experiences yes
hilarious just in the Antares blowout
the other day which was a drag and that
was an tears was verbal science his
mission to be to resupply the space
station not man and they quickly said
well they quickly the officials quickly
announced that the astronauts on the
space shuttle are are fun even though
this was a supply ship lies on to them
that they'll do just fine until the
I'm thinking then why would you have to
send this one in the first place well
then plan for something going wrong from
time to time I bet you have stuff in
your cabinet next time that there's a
hurricane and you got to pull down your
salmon in a can your tuna fish let's
call it a heart and you drive somewhere
okay it took you three days though not
to change the subject but you didn't
leave yeah I was hit by or an exam date
your fingers crossed
yeah we lost electricity and so that was
but that's not exactly rockets
no it's not it's not so so we did learn
some things the design of the space
shuttle anything else how serious
yesterday great ice is a big deal people
people who are working on the ground
controller Bronson well it seems like
about a 1 in 300 chance that it will
work and people are launching anyway it
shows you it could right ok says after
the fact before the fact
oh we were all waving arms and pounding
I know my old Aeronautics professors
that you know don't ever ever do this i
paraphrase but it was done anyway for
financial reasons it was really and I
know we're answering this question it
was really during the Nixon
administration when he decided that for
the sake of votes NASA jobs were more
important really than the NASA
exploration and the evidence of this if
you look at Nixon's Oval Office at one
point he's got Earthrise Apollo 8 on
Isaac Newton's birthday Eve 1968
and then six months later after he's got
the votes in California he takes that
picture down to puts up another one Wow
it was not a believer Wow
it was just being a politician I don't
know just politicians politicians have
hard jobs journalism you couldn't see
the hands any hands going up do it again
gesture zero what we need to get the
space-boat yes we do ok so this is from
at this my man remain at peace my man
from Twitter this is
god his name is Cod his handle is at
this my man how it balanced the burning
desire of our genetic predisposition to
explore with the need to ensure safe
passage I think he's kind of that's a
great question he's kind of talking also
about maybe commercial space flight let
me add some punctuation this and it's
going straight to you on this bill
you're an engineer and you will tell the
launch people look you shouldn't do that
because it should be little safer than
that that that could go wrong don't do
that at some point somebody's got to
push the button launch today oh yeah you
have a [ __ ] engineers gonna make some
time you have to stop loosing the
engineers and get on I'm sorry what what
is that threshold we decide well that's
what we call management on it so the
managers have to be literate enough to
know what the acceptable level of risk
is and but the night that the night mind
would say no risk is acceptable so they
oh no no that's not a true fact that's a
false fact that's a false fact no you've
been in automobiles and there's a risk
of text yeah I'm sure you have a sense
that something could go wrong and these
guys the people who fly in Rockets have
a sense that something could go wrong
and I'm very sorry about the Virgin
Galactic crash the other day in a
surprising result and one that they will
straighten out and that I claim is not
just part of the process was part of the
management process where you learn what
is acceptable and I think what was going
on changing the subject to the Space
Shuttle in the previous question a lot
of people do the risk was a lot higher
than was advertised and they pressed on
anyway at Virgin Galactic it looks like
perhaps the risk was underestimated that
is actually more dangerous than and
people were saying in other words there
wasn't deliberate deliberate ignoring of
the facts there was ignorance of the
facts
so we'll see what happened if the
reasons to why the feather the feather
and things a surprising result why that
would cause trouble and it could have to
do I'm shooting from the up as an
engineer could have to do
the materials involved so this is the
brakes would put on too early the air
brakes are just too high the too many
molecules in the atmosphere and at that
level if you've waited a little longer
where you got a fewer molecules per
cubic something you might have been just
working with the data we have stay tuned
there are people who are experts at
figuring this out Wow okay all right
Jeff that's beautiful here we go this is
from Carlos and Carlos this CBS Ellen
Twitter wants to know this
how easy is rocketry these days then
tough recently do we pretty much have it
figured out
or are we just kind of playing around
let me shake that question back to you
bill we've been boldly going where
hundreds are gone before into low-earth
orbit I would think that low Earth orbit
should be zero risk at this point given
how long we've been doing it and how
many people have done it so that if
we're gonna put lives at risk it should
be by doing something we've never done
before if I were to think of an
acceptable risk it'd be doing something
that's never done before not doing
something hundreds have done before you
so we just saw in back in in November in
October we saw two disasters two space
there was a early November so two
disasters people not even going into
orbit so here's how I say to you you may
be mixing the modern verb is conflating
an air traffic Eric airplane airliner
travel with rocket travel a few hundred
is not that many right you think about
how many airplanes people tried to build
in the early 1900's and how many crash a
failed from the films it looks like one
hundred percent of it I saw that the
film because the horses a hundred or a
thousand isn't that biggest sample size
really and the other constraint when it
comes to the entire rocket the orbital
sciences wrote the bloob that was an old
rocket being repurposed being
refurbished okay so so are you saying
that maybe we need to go up into little
Earth orbit so much that it becomes like
well this this is what he's saying this
is what
so say it says many is a hundred sounds
as many as a hundred flight sounds like
it's not that many isn't a statistical
scheme you think yeah you know many
flights take off every day and land
every day it's I can't something I do if
some Chi have a video I'll show you it
is some countless scary numbers of its
countless scary number entirely there
are about a hundred thousand passengers
in the air at any given time if you said
to the Wright brothers you know you know
in about a hundred years we're gonna
have 100,000 people in the air at any
given time yeah they they yeah and
that's why I say about space travel
we're just comparing the two accidents
ontari is a very old rocket being
refurbished and it had a leaky fuel line
it sounds like or a leaky pump and then
the Virgin Galactic rocket was a
brand-new rocket and so it has brand-new
problems the in-between ones is what
we're all hoping to internally in
between we want in between so Carlos
there's your answer
Thank You rocketry not easy hopefully
we'll get to a place where it is that
place will be anytime somebody said this
is a brand new thing transfer Letterman
asks sir Branson are you gonna go and
the first one on the first flight yes
mm-hmm
so there you have it if it has that
rocket smell you see a cup of sandwich
stains on the sea that's the rocket you
when it's right all right let's go to
deep pop Kremlin deep REM @astro friend
he wants to know this he says I can
understand that it's justified to spend
resources on space exploration but why
risk human life in the name of tourism
he is quite emphatic about this soda
park you have the option of not buying a
ticket you don't be okay you don't have
to buy a ticket you don't
to go nobody's thinking in the abstract
so stay here and so under people who are
willing to take the risk will throw down
and go up is there any benefit what's in
it to everybody who flies in space by
all accounts has this new appreciation
for the earth when you see the Earth
from above apparently I've not done it
except by the TV and it changes your
perspective you realize what a fragile
small world we live on
yeah but Bill in the early days there
were joyriding airplane fliers right
yeah all right so they must have known
risks and some of them would have died
and that was and that was the tourists
dick risk so it's clearly people will do
this
people get on rollercoasters to take
risks no no if if they if they if you
talk some was a hundred you pretend
chance they were one in a hundred chance
they would dive I get my roller coaster
nobody take it out that's right but if
you say this work 100 chance you'll die
flying not Everest people line up around
the watch is what they do why what's the
difference I guess you're going
someplace new you're going where no one
has gone before and Mount Everest is
just Mount Everest we're all coasters
are pretty much everywhere yeah there's
only one there's only one space to go to
people who seek thrills for deep ocean
Ares apparently people who don't take
risks get eliminated that's something
about us the people the team members get
eliminated to survive survive longer
than those who never took the risk if
that's how you got a word that sentence
taking his long term
right short-term disaster long-term
benefit better may accrue to your
descendants but only if you have to send
us before you go on that risky venture
hey right otherwise you are wiped from
the gene pool oh you sorry you pull it
off you can't you go over the hill make
the discovery you come back alright okay
we're doing it never come back and start
general people come with your colony
yeah okay what else super cool man all
right this is Matt Kenan not Kevin Elyot
at Twitter he wants to know this can we
alter the popular notion in the media
that a failure means nothing they
learned that go for it bill
that's all you that was I was charmed by
the many many news stories after the
entire East rocket blew up and then
after the virgin galactic crash does
this mean the end of SpaceX are you
kidding
those people are gonna redouble their
efforts they're gonna go back out and
harder than ever they're gonna work as
hard as they possibly can to solve these
problems because they see the great
promise right are you joking me mr.
question person and how do you really
feel Bill for crying out loud
know when something goes wrong you just
try even harder right otherwise you get
out competed by the other guy who does
succeed Lee try order and you know what
that doesn't matter that makes it makes
no difference what it is across the
board that kind of general approach if I
ever approach to life now you two guys I
have ancestry yes where I imagine people
told you you couldn't do a lot of things
this is true and look at you both yeah
ruling the airwaves yeah I come from
that as my lineage my great grandfather
invented the horse diaper and a lot of
people don't realize they were like
that's a disgusting premise why would
you ever want to do that if you're going
to Central Park that could be just the
thing there you go so Bank Grandpop nice
for that is that true huh is that true
now Neil you know better than not about
space exploration is how do you evacuate
your bowels and empty your bladder and
this is a very serious problem that has
to be solved when you're gonna fly in
space yeah at zero gravity
yeah then you're a horse your owner of a
horse and you have
your zero g LG of manure a usable thing
how you might you drew me in good
alright no reason to doubt it mighta
worked it up when we come back more
stark talk radio's cosmic queries
this is still star talking I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson check nice across for me
yes sir William I'm sitting in answering
questions yeah the topic is is is space
is space travel hard space exploration
rockets hard rockets are hard rockets
are hard just so we know bill you you
tweet at the science guy
yes Chuck nice you tweeted Chuck nice
comment yes sir
and start talked we treated start
talking that tweeted start on radio yes
that's right follow what was going on
here so Chuck what bill and I have not
seen these questions I mean have I
brought him along because their rocket
questions I would not be able to answer
that's why I'm going to warn for back it
up and the engineering perspective yes
exactly so what do you have for us all
right so here's a speaking of
engineering wonders let's talk about
little rosetta steel a so this from and
East End's who wants to know what for
another civilization see the comets and
asteroids cetera with organic material
trying to propagate life around the
universe is that feasible not only where
he's talking about is the fact that we
were able to land on the comet so he's
in a bit of longer version he says would
we be able to actually do something like
that take who we are and instead of
sending a rocket we put who we are on a
comet and that who we are go out and
leave our solar system and go forth
there's a little problem with that okay
okay the very act of landing on a comet
means you have given your rocket the
exact orbital trajectory of the comet
itself let's start with wide another
engine and push it to us yeah well could
do that no so if you match the the comet
or the asteroid then what does it mean
either on the other day you don't need
as much just to have success I got it
now no no no the asteroid Neil yes from
an engineering standpoint a mine
asteroid yeah I've heard about the
recessions for you so what Bill all the
kids are trying to do yeah
a big thing they want of mine is watch
it yeah work and what they want to do is
take solar panels to make electricity
from the Sun electrolyze the water so
that becomes how h2o becomes hydrogen
and oxygen break it apart then put it
back together as rocket fuel in a very
fast fashion and get a drawing get
itself so this is not I mean it's
extraordinary but not completely
unreasonable but so you're saying you
would go to the asteroid that is a
source of water at for future rocket
fuel for you it's a filling station
that's your honesty culture to come yeah
I'm good I'm good with that and then
there are water rich asteroids that are
not comments so right so that's cool i
these are be filling stations yeah look
like a standard 5 rocket where every
ounce of fuel that you gonna use your
entire journey you're leaving with earth
to take I think you went into the rocket
equation problem
yeah so to give us two minutes on the
rocket equation well everybody you know
how heavy the thing you're gonna try to
lift is your payload that what you pay
for and think about this
the moment you like the rocket engine
the rocket weighs less with every moment
of time that passes more fuel is burned
in the rocket weighs less Anthony
so the great deep calculus rocket
equation question is how much fuel do
you start with right because some of the
fuel is to move other feel you haven't
burned yet that's it to run it later on
your trajectory great it's pull-ups
you're yeah you're lifting your own
bodyweight so yes if you have long arms
and you are heavy it is very difficult
to do pull that true and if you pooped
while you were pulling on you every
night would be easier so this is the
point of the rocket equation against a
recoil the same way used to make the
pull it's easier for you anymore
okay but those are your third order
effects okay it's that okay all right
well there you have it Andy the answer
well what other question is you don't
you really wouldn't need to do it unless
it's a filling station that's the end
that's the end all right let's go to a
Jake Knickerbocker right not to be
confused with the New York
knickerbockers Jay says images of the
comet show in tumbling at a high rate of
rotation if that is accurate how they
will set up match its rotation to the
comet so feel a could make a stable
landing regarding the failed harpoon how
are they sure it didn't fire or is it
possible any sensors indicating such
simply failed and it is in fact tethered
so he's I don't know there's rotating
all my favors fast when you watch the
animation on the electric in RAM it
looks fast but it's a rotation rate was
about once every 12 earth hours that's
not really all that well so twice as
fast as the Earth spins and as a
difficult deep space problem to get your
Rosetta probe rotating at about the same
speed but however to the questions point
I would say that if they show the
rotation on the jiff at the actual rate
that would be a really boring [ __ ] take
to set there for 12 hours I'd like to
think they're around furthermore it is
tethered by gravity
even though it's a very low mass thing
it still it still has gravity which is
why it bounced it went up however was
overkill me and then came back okay next
question I'm a kilometer as far as the
sensors not sensing it the plum tree is
pretty reliable and I got a question for
bill I mean it's named Rosetta because
it was the rosetta stone which was
helped us decode ancient languages in
particular Egyptian hieroglyphics and
taught me Spanish
okay so but the fight light I didn't do
my homework on five eyes you lose fire
light they have to build you know I said
NIF out there really yeah a sea nymph
then where if you go towards it you
crash into the rocks I should know yeah
what a name who wants to know
check out planetary door we're gonna
read Emily walk through on this blog
it's in there disclaimer Kevin II can't
say that
no no disclaimer oh just climber I'm to
see your Chuck here's one dr. Tyson used
the word disclaimer when I think he
meant disclosure oh he's right totally
call me out it's a rookie mistake
there you go all right let's move on
this is Mark Parton
good day I heard that G apostrophe da
why no I wasn't good night good night it
was a breach at the regional accent EJ
teaching voice good day good day uh I
heard that feeling bounced off the
comment before settling back to the
surface several hours later the low
bounce was due to extremely low gravity
after seeing the pictures of the solid
rock surface
I wondered how something with such a low
gravity borne rocks if this and other
comets and asteroids were formed from
leftover dust from the formation of a
solar system how did this dust compress
into such solid materials without
significant gravity these people are
doing their homework yes the thing is
that was great good day mark so when
you're in deep space there's nothing to
slow you down if you're a particle of
dust one of the strange insights that
troubled me as a young man and I still
stroke my chin from time to time and
you're still a young man when you look
at the dust on the bookshelf it is
strange thing that not only is the earth
pulling the dust down or toward the
center there the dust is pulling the
earth up so in deep space when you have
dust many many kilometres apart and
they're being attracted they actually
slam together at a pretty high speed and
this was one of the ideas behind the
Philly probe was to figure out what is
the asteroid like is it puffy meringue E
or is it rocky solid E and is it a cream
puff or a walnut that's a common it's we
know to comment so it'll be mostly
evaporative is right right so so here's
the thing Bill which is worse to me is
quite cool it was not until recently
that we had any clue what the structural
integrity of comets or asteroids
actually is mm-hmm and we've seen
comments go around the Sun and just the
tidal force of the Sun breaks it apart
into the 20 pieces we had a comet slam
into Jupiter it was one piece at one
time and it became 24 broken pieces
afterwards and no one went to it with a
sledgehammer
it was just the gravitational stress of
going by Jupiter that did that at all so
we don't really know how tightly held
together these things are that makes
part of the mesh that's part of their
mission now there's some asteroids that
are the fragments of broken
planetesimals those would be chunks of
rock and get out of their way right but
comets and some other asteroids they
might be rubble piles just rocks that
you gather together there are rocks that
we do asteroids that we know have the
density whether the material is made of
rock but you calculate the density and
it's the density of something almost as
light as water exactly so you it's got
rock but if the rock isn't all the way
through it that's got this is porous or
it's good it's just a pile of rubble
travel together pretending like it's one
solid object Oh like a bunch of little
thugs hey you guys have worked up
feeling in here the island of
let's see allowed to pull out his day
and look up the answer I mean we're
suppose that's the same thing I should
know and it has to do with the sun-god
law and he had an island and feel a is
the amount okay there you have it that's
this asteroid feel like sounds a little
Latin rather than a week when you got
the pH going oh yeah yeah okay so 67 CP
is John Smith ever discovers a Connor
its share cheerio under pressure
don't take it what else you got alright
so yeah by the way it was a great answer
for mark there's your answer mark and
this is this is how oh by the way just
while we're there if there's an asteroid
headed our way and you want to deflect
it yes and you late and you send
something that's going to push it and
you later learn that it's made of a
rubble pile you're the push and hit some
of the rocks and not the others right so
you want to know what this thing is made
of and how its held together before you
do any of these rescue missions or any
kind of mission at all and like bill
said that's part of the reason why we
went there in the first place and this
is a big push interplanetary studies
assessing the near-earth objects right I
mentioned planetary norm tonight is
disclosure what's the what's the word I
use I'm so from there disclaimer I said
yeah Barry disclaiming anything I'm
embarrassed okay alright that's been one
another great question all right here we
go here we go here we go here we go this
is a pretty yeah this is Chris Van Gundy
a pretty simple straightforward question
all right how can we determine the
difference between a brown dwarf and a
large
rogue planet hmm
yeah we showed a rogue planet in cosmos
and show that with infrared filters is
still sort of radiating the heat left
over from its formation
there it is hotly debated still yeah but
what is the boundary between a brown
dwarf and a planet just at what point do
you say this is a planet there's not
flight and now you got like the
beginnings of a star and then when do
you have a star alright so the beginning
well Jupiter is is still a wait a little
too light to have it's a star that never
made it but it's not like it was close
okay and so Juber is not massive dr. B
so we have people working on how to
define brown dwarfs is it chemically
what's going on in the atmosphere is it
temperature but then the temperature
changes over the life of the baby this
whole kids gonna have to relearn I know
and then as the temperature changes the
chemistry the atmosphere changes so what
are you gonna bout it in order to say
what kind of object it is and is the
object changing it so so it's still a
hot lead discussed topic look at all PNM
about 3 Kelvin 3 degrees above absolute
zero
but it's hotter than that yeah well wait
for that temperature they start brown
dwarf planet would be I mean it could be
as much as I don't know several hundred
degrees Celsius I mean several hundred
degrees several hundred kelvins I'm
sorry
let me think hold on I'm sorry sorry
let's let us agree on what scale we're
using first yes okay how about Celsius
surface of the Sun is between five to
six thousand degrees Celsius okay so a
brown and red cooler red giant stars are
around three thousand two thousand
degrees
you start getting brown dwarf land when
you're 1000 degrees eight hundred
degrees and then hot planets would be
you know 400 degrees would be four yeah
around there around based on my memory
of how all this association note well
know the surface of the Sun at 6000
degrees Celsius sounds hot it is hot but
a bolt of lightning is a little hotter
what yeah oh yeah that was
because a bolt of lightning is hotter
than the Sun excuse me - sir not the
center of this on the surface okay
it was like I got stuck with the surface
of the Sun yes no see that wouldn't
there's a bolt of lightning now you're
talking okay all right
I don't know do we have time for one
more it's quick okay okay here we go and
excluding the size of this is from the
Sun does Venus have more in common with
the gas giants than terrestrial planets
affect people let's find the middle oh
no no we want everybody to know that we
want people in kindergarden to know that
just got bitch-slapped by cosmic queries
you are back on Startalk on the other
grass place and Bill Nye is my is my
expert in residence today you go dream
we are doing cosmic lairs
edition the topic check night SID
rocket rocket and rocket science rocket
science and I know me some of the
rockets but build on those more some
rockets and I want list engineering
versus astrophysics yeah so I didn't
want to tackle this annoying tastes that
taste great together 1988 called they
want their commercial all right back
into this this is home a I'm sorry Jose
oh yeah
does do him some some some regional
accents yes so this is launching a space
shuttle was originally estimators very
low-cost but in the end it up to a
million dollars per launch which made it
kind of a manageable do you think the
same can happen now with private
companies as they face the huge
challenges and risks of space flight
time will tell by the way 1 billion was
an estimate for a while now all in
people are throwing around the word the
number one and a half billion personal
shelf life so here's the thing when you
the Space Shuttle was built by NASA and
their 10 NASA centers and this was a
brilliant idea in 1958 it made the space
program if I may onion cancel a bowl 10
centers across the country across the
country in eight states too big to fail
too many congressional interests to get
shut down right and so now everybody
keep in mind when we talk about space
exploration technology SpaceX and we
talked about Boeing these companies are
taking billions of dollars to produce
rockets for the larger good
probably good DUI astronauts from many
nations to space but when you visit
SpaceX the factory is a big horseshoe
the train cars show up full of steel and
aluminum they unload this stuff that
goes into the factory they hammer it out
to the right shape they stir welded with
the world's largest star welder machine
which is a fabulous friction thing then
they put all the wires and then they
pressure they make the British tanks and
they install impersonates goes around
the big horseshoe the big letter EU and
goes back on a different train car and
goes to Cape Canaveral or Vandenberg Air
Force Base ready to fly that's the
premise of the bit so it is believed
that you'll be able to lower the cost of
making rockets so we will see are there
so these are is there expertise that
NASA had that these new companies buy
new I mean more recently developed
companies do or do not have time will
tell when it comes to Boeing they've
been building all disclosure markets for
years of disclosure I worked on going
okay either way
you worked on the jumbo jet works on 747
and very cool so your IC in your hand
you have a pin yes that's from the Latin
word pin a feather so we write we used
to write with quills correct now
airplane the shaft of an arrow is the
fuselage right the tail feathers are the
antenna on the airplane 7m finish and my
understanding of your experience your
three children there's been there's been
quite something successful and phenomena
mission I'm just gonna let a taper off
but you're gonna yeah that's good that's
very cool let's go to Facebook and James
fish and James I gotta add something to
this
so the shovel would have been less per
launch right if we have 50 launches a
year but they not to be too dangerous
and complicated too complicated and the
parts were being used and then when do
you replace it do you need a new part or
when this youth battle-tested and so
part of a business model as always can
you reuse the the vessel and modern
airplanes are used multiple times a days
if you have a fly in airplanes now are
younger than the planes right if you
flew an airplane and each time you threw
it away that's a different business
model real answer how do we do it we
must be crazy all right let's go to
Facebook and James fish and here's what
Jameis James has to say there's a lot of
talk about quantum computers and how
they can change the face of predictive
modeling what potential could it have to
change artificial intelligence and the
singularity when computers there is
smartest people but computers and the
quantum computing thing is electricity
and right now someone literally has to
shovel the coal to keep the robots going
so I'm all for this robot uprising as
long as there's an infinite supply of
electricity well what if they're
controlling the nuclear power plants
that they're doing okay knock yourselves
out there is control of the grip I think
it's a long way off the computer has the
quantum though control the grip right
and they're not gonna wait for you to
plug them in for them to take over your
life who's gonna show all the coal they
will oh is it leave it to version of
themselves that will show them any well
so anyways you speak like that it's
weird that the robots need some special
source of energy
so do we yet because you fool three at
least times a day just just what we need
Orson
us by means of in Panaji ahead that's
arrow and so you're saying the sort of
six of one okay so by the way changes
subject back to me I have a little thing
about the singular okay no just to be
clear there's an astrophysicist at the
table if you use the word single arrow
you have to clarify and I'm using
nothing about the universe you're not
talking about the beginning universe or
the senator black hole or any other
previous use of the word singularity go
I love this power to be like a human
brain and in my book undeniable I have a
little discussion about this you can go
to places in the world where people have
not made a phone call not made a cell
phone call not made a phone call I'm not
saying they won't change in the next
little while but it's gonna be just it
may be later than you think when there's
a robot uprising taking over the world
the robot show up in western China and
they go there's no place to plug in man
I'm sorry dude
and they've they're not very productive
whether women take over the world
I think I agree with Bill there's
there's nothing about it that sounds
impending to me okay though it be
intending to others which is the perfect
setup for like the cult right the world
is going to come into it little change
really soon really fast just join the
band right just right he's not asking
you to send money oh yeah I wanna get
breaker fault on the show the big the
exponent of the singularity would get
try to get him on Startalk okay so he
can speak for himself rather than me
coming here with others have said about
Annie maybe right okay
alright well there you have it don't
worry about it baby
alright okay let's go to Robert Hartley
it was also coming to us from Facebook
hello guys I'm from Auckland New Zealand
and in case Neil ass
just in case Neil asked because
sometimes you want to know where people
are from in regards to the on Terry's
field watch how much doubt would the
team have to have that the mission would
go unsuccessfully before making the
decision to abort so what is the
protocol for an aborted launch what has
to happen where you go different
canceling a launch okay and there's the
board in flight so canceling we're gonna
put it off or postponing it's a probably
a better verb to place forward to place
a headed to place later
so postponing is what we're postponing
is where people ask themselves is this
going to work or not abort generally
means once the things flying and it's
going to cause trouble should we blow it
up in the case of lost on Terry's launch
it was self up blown so self okay with
the self-appointed was a design feature
what's that sound so anyway I know what
you mean but this is why you have
managers and this is why you have
managers you want to be literate with
technically you want to know what's
going on you can make decisions based on
learning input from their support can
you be a good manager going to manager
of schools you have to be an engineer to
manage engineers well let me ask you
this so many of the fortune 500 country
companies are run by engineers okay so
what could welcome a better tech
companies yeah so is there a connection
in other words could such a tech company
be run by somebody who's not engineering
savvy and the answer is rocket launches
you really want people charged with
experience so this is you know just to
talk about the Planetary Society yet
again on our board is Scott Hubbard who
became the Mars our NASA yeah so there
was Mars the faster better cheaper was
the the way of thinking the modern
people throw his mantra this is what
we're gonna impress a better cheaper so
there were some successful missions but
there was Mars climate orbiter thing
which went off into deep space because
we interchanged English units of metric
you went off in these faith instead of
arriving at Mars yes
and then Mars Polar Lander which became
Mars polar crasher because the landing
gear deployed and the software thought
that had been on the surface but there
was a shake and the software thought it
was on the surface but it was still in
the space and a crash so we brought in
NASA brought in Scott Hubbard who was
the manager he managed it he figured out
who knew what he was doing and who
didn't any make some personnel changes
and then we had the successful landing
subsidy to the fire your Greta you don't
fire
so that's ancient wisdom wanders it's
management as well as technical problem
alright so there you have question all
right here we go this is from Matt Eli
and Matt wants to know this if life were
on a comet would we know it also I heard
mentioned that they are trying to see
how much of Earth's water came from
comets furthermore their amino acids on
these bodies these are asked us with
carbon and double bond double bond
oxygen oxygen looks like a building
blocks of life and so exactly so where
is the line drawn between an amino acid
out there in space and you and me Neil I
thought you're gonna chime in with some
brilliant insight Astrophysical
astrobiological insight well there's
some there ideas put forth back in the
1960s and 70s led by Fred Hoyle and
there's collaborated with Rama C II who
suggested that perhaps there were bugs
in space and that if the solar system
moved through a virus contaminated cloud
that the whole earth would be
contaminated all at once and they put
that forth as a reason for the 1918 flu
epidemic okay so buzz has them okay
disease the notion that you can
accomplish both clues in space why can't
you have complex organisms right right
so
that it's really great science fiction
material but it doesn't really hold on
analysis because to make complete
articles you need high rate of collision
with particles and gas clouds are very
low density and so you don't have the
experimenting the chemical experimenting
that would go on on a planet's surface
and so if there were life on a comet and
it was microbial there's not any way we
would all as you land on it my dad finds
the ratify some good so which means we
got to go there we've got your question
we're there when are we alone in the
universe and where did we come from
that's why we explore I want to know
where we're going you've been listening
to star talk radio's cosmic Larry's
edition the space exploration subject
helped us by Edition thingy
Bill Nye thanks for coming on not you
New York I'm gonna be calling you all
the time you realize as always as always
good having you Chuck nice nice at
Twitter Bill Nye the Science Guy you can
find me at Neil Tyson if you were
interested as always I bid you farewell
and look good he bid you farewell and
encourages to purchase you two as always
I encourage one at all to keep looking
up this is Startalk
you